uh in today's lecture uh i will talk
about
one invest very interesting type of
endgame
which is which actually can can occur
after already like seven moves only um
which is anti-grown fault and game
which usually is considered as pretty
harmless for
for for black jewelry black doesn't mind
you know going for such a game but
there have been some recent developments
that i wanted to share with you guys
in in this opening and this end game
pretty much that's why
you know i brought it to this today's
lecture in saying again in insane in the
end game
because pretty much it's just an end
game which basically starts only after
move number seven
so uh and there have been recently games
between taymur ajabov and
massim vashila graf and
[Music]
i would like to basically talk about
those games mostly about one of them
however
you know i believe that
the mod basically what was happening
happening this game
was sort of challenged what is the
theoretical let's say state of uh
this opening uh because normally it was
considered as totally harmless for black
however
those games proved because they rejected
won twice
against mvl and he proved that there
could be
posed certain problems to to black and
they are not entirely easy to resolve
so let's get started and the
the this opening starts this end game
sort of starts with another three knight
f6
c4 g6 then c3 d5
c takes d5 knight takes d5 and right now
white can start
with move either h4
uh followed by if black plays h6 then e4
and knight c3 did xc3 or beat xc3 but
this is
these two different type of position you
take c3 and the such endgame
arises or black can uh do
here uh move welcome back back and play
he remove bishop g7
e4 knight 63 detective queen take z1
queen takes d1
and this is the end game i played also
with black pieces
myself or go for the classical let's say
approach basically immediate after
knight takes d5
immediate e4 uh
okay if immediate e4 knight takes c3
detects c3
and queen knight quinto is one king
takes d1 so this end game
has been always at least icos here is
always totally uh
harmless no danger not not causing any
problems here for
or for black whatsoever and uh
i was out to the i will say even that
i was considering that this is type of
the variation that white wants to play
if i want to just to make a draw and
that's it and
this is what i was always thinking i was
pretty much nearly always
lazy to analyze this you know in detail
however there are you know recent games
especially by you know
rajab who is one of the best players uh
in the world
made me kind of like reconsider maybe
there is some maybe there are some ideas
here for
for why that could be uh causing some
problems for black and
the my discoveries are pretty
interesting i i believe so let me share
it with you guys
and um here black in the one one of the
games
for f6
and this move is by far i was
considering always this move
as the best move in this position as the
the best move in the other game uh
maxine virtual graph trying to move
knight d7
uh trained knight d7 uh instead of f6
started 97 and but i'll mostly focus on
the game after f6
because this personally i always
consider move f6 also as the best move
in this position
and the idea of f6 is very
straightforward it's basically playing
with e5
fight for the center we bring spawn to
the center and
[Music]
have this kind of symmetrical position
in which
unlikely anything can can happen
and i also played myself in finger 2015
and i managed to win a nice game with
black so
even this kind of like shows that
i was sort of like before those games
happened i was sort of like in favor of
this
uh line uh with black and i kind of
liked it
here however uh you know with emory
above
come on played move h4 which is sort of
modern approach here
uh and it's totally a style of you know
lc zero alpha zero and so on this neural
engines
h4 basically you know try by white tries
to create some pressure on the king side
and the idea is to play of course with
h5 and
if we can basically create some or
provoke some weaknesses
maybe we can some squares this
definitely uh would be
great great news for for white so uh
after h4
uh the theories are just two moves here
for black one move is h5
and one move is e5
personally i think that e5
is better move h5 i don't like
h5 i simply don't like and
let's let's see why but
first let me talk because h5 is what mvl
chosen
in this game however
and i would like to discuss move e5
first because this i think
this is what i wanted to play myself and
i
still think that's basically better move
but things
even though persian seems to be pretty
equal there's there is still some
some pressure that the white can exert
here on black and
it is not entirely trivial to how to
play this
so idea of a5 is basically to meet h5
which of course h4 was
with value of h5 with this move h5 move
g5 and trying to block the king side
this on the other hand uh
creates as quick square on f5 which
while can try to
exploit and also g4 uh basically why
we'll try to
white's main idea right now is to
basically trade a light square bishops
and you know jump with the knight to
g4 or f5 squares and they you know
have this kind of in sponsor in this
such structure there should be
why should be better in general pretty
much everywhere
still black is very solid no no question
about
it but still i believe that
uh if this bishop will be traded and
knight will come to all squares white
should have better chances
and here magnus carlsen uh man
played against mvl himself in 2020
late 2020 in december i think some of
those tournaments like
air things or skilling i'm not exactly
sure
i don't remember right now but i saw
this game the magnus played right now
uh bishop e3 but knight h2 minus playing
with knight h2
and the idea of knight h2 is very
straightforward but it's basically play
bishop e2 play bishop g4
and go for such
endgame here basically you know explore
you know
apply this uh this plan of uh train the
light square bishops
so uh after uh knight h2 in the game of
magnus followed i think
the note bishop c5 fault
uh bishop e6 for bishop b6 and
right now magnus got very very nice
advantage
and stable advantage of bishop e2 a 97
bishop g4
following the plan of training those
light square bishops king f7
logical uh also logical has to play king
e2
not only move but we're pretty logical
uh
knight c5 we can just straight king take
e6
f and f3 and the point is that uh
white has better pawn structure and
while like black bishop on f8 is a no
like not a good bishop
knight knight white knight comes to g4
uh and
presumably at some point in the future
to f5
black has pretty much very little
counter play and white can you know try
to push it for very very very long time
so in the game follow knight a4 rook b1
bishop e7
bishop d2 rook d8 group d1 all normal
moves
but white slowly you know in general
instead of disabled positions you have
to sort of apply
do not hurry and uh gradually improve
the position
and this is exactly what magnus is doing
here
uh knight b6 knight g4 being the knight
rook d7 bishop e3 rook to z1 takes takes
knight c8
of course if y will be allowed to take
on b6
this would uh certainly you know
give white better chances because then
on the light squares and white knight
will be pretty much
unbeatable right now black tried to keep
the knights on the board and always have
an idea of basically trading
those knives and try to save the game in
this way and this is exactly
how mvl managed to defend this against
magnus in
[Music]
in in their game however here
you know here magnus because heron is
playing knight h6 and i think this move
is a little bit premature because after
b6
the sorry uh
knight f5 knight d6 essentially what
happens is that those knights are
getting traded
if both sides are getting traded
then rogues are going to be likely
traded on the d file and
position simplifying simplifies more and
more and
eventually black simply managed to
save save it so after let's say this
this
king of seven seven king rook got out
rook d8 for offering trader trader
groups perhaps it was better to keep the
rules on the board but anyway
this followed and here um basically it
was too little to prove anything and the
game and
the draw between this is the game magnus
versus
carson vs mvl um
so uh coming back here to move knight c8
this is what happened in this game
here in this type of position because i
i think it's a nice example because
uh this side this simulator is going to
happen with different move orders
different let's say
um i don't know scenarios or what can
what what both sides do uh but you know
with the end game with such let's say
material balance
uh one pair of looks traded a
like scriptures traded and now white
controller let's say light squares on
the queen side
sorry king side uh is could be quite
common in such end game there's
such type of opening that's why it's i
think good to know how to react
uh how to continue here with white and
what white needs to do in general is
basically beginning creating second
weekend on the queen side this time
so so i slowly advanced imposing the
queen side maybe
slowly got putting some pressure there
uh white can
uh can probably do it of course with
perfect defense black we should be able
to hold it but it's still all like
uh it's not like black person is lost or
something
but it's clearly unpleasant to play so i
will consider maybe another series this
uh outputs are playing maybe a4 let's
say knight d6 maybe move king d3 maybe
bring this king to c2 at first or deal
king c2
and maybe a wise idea we need to play
bishop c5 at some point we trade these
bishops if
you know maybe you can play move before
at some point kim b3 slowly pushing and
pushing those pawns uh
forward on them on the queen side
and gradually increa improving the
position
and putting more and more putting more
and more pressure on
on black here and still i believe with
correct defense it should be
holdable but uh it's definitely you know
black definitely has sorry what
definitely has some chances to win this
so uh having talked about that let's
move back
a little bit to what uh i think
after knight h2 black should be doing
black should play move bishop c5
basically in this type of position is
this type of end game
usually this bishop from c8 needs to be
quickly developed to c5
if only given a chance and this is
exactly what
my nvidia should have played here bishop
c5 bishop c5
and the idea is basically that pawn on
f2
nothing more uh straightforward than
that
just attacking pawn on f2 and okay
another idea is basically start bishop
e3 and basically
you know keep our keyboard bishop active
and
right now why should play i guess king
sorry bishop e2
and the point is that bishop takes f2
right now it doesn't lead any to
anything good
for uh for black because after bishop
takes f2 knight g4
takes takes will wait it's pretty much
forced because otherwise if bishop
retreats somewhere
knight xf6 is simply lose the loss
completely lost for black coupon g5
false
so black has to take
white takes with the bishop and let's
say
knight d7 and let's say right now we can
start with
k2 but also we can play move b4 followed
by king e2
making sure this bishop doesn't come
back to c5
and here white has big advantage
the lack of the pawn you pretty much
cannot even feel it white the black has
extra one because
bishop on g4 is such a dominant bishop
such a dominant piece
that its pretty much
extra pawn is for black irrelevant in
this position
white has big big advantage definitely
so black cannot take the pawn on f2 even
if black cannot take pawn on f2
black should play with king e7 and the
that's
what black should generally try to play
for
and even and right now bishop takes f2
already could be a fret
so white should you know waste the tempo
for move king e1
and you know try to defend this pawn on
um on f2
because already pawn on f6 was protected
so let's say bishop g4 would be pretty
much uh not good because bishop takes f2
and black is simply winning the pawn and
black is better so this would
therefore black white has to play with
king e1 try to defend this pawn
and right now good strategy for black is
basically to keep those
try to keep make uh
[Music]
i mean try to avoid trading those light
square bishops and that's why
bishop e6 is a very good move right now
for black in my opinion
idea of bishop e6 is to basically meet
bishop g4
with simply bishop f7 and i think in
this type of position
um you know black should generally
hold with those bishops on the board
even if white knight comes to f5
like this okay and so what it will just
come to f5 but it will not create any
frets
black would just play rook t8 now it
will come to f5 and let's say black
would just play king of 8
and there is no pretty much follow uh
pretty much no follow-up and meantime
black would begin counter play on the
king queen side with bishop on
preserving his bishop on f7 generates
the significant counter play on the
queen side for
for black because there will be ideas of
bishop c4
there will be ideas of basically playing
a5 a4 so let's just play some random
few random let's say knight f1 for by
knight g3 uh knight five
we can start with rook d8 or we can
start also a5 it doesn't
matter much senior g3 rook d8 knight f5
king f8 and yeah like for instance right
now black can
uh quickly go for some counter play in
the
on the queen side uh idea of you know
playing for f form
is definitely interesting but whenever
whitelist mover can wonders we also
bishop c4
so it's not easy to to make that uh
really really work
and i think that in this type of
position uh you know
i don't i simply don't think that white
has a sufficient let's say play here
uh of course like we still slightly
better but it's
very pretty much on the um
is bouncing on you know
it's close to nothing close to nothing
in my opinion because the bishop on f7
grants significant let's say counter
play
that's why i believe that this is simply
good position for
uh for black and this is what i think
mark uh sorry mvl should have played for
um
should have gone for uh instead uh mvl
chose move h5 but okay here coming back
to this position
uh i thought that maybe a little bit
better try for white is to play with
bishop e3
and the idea of bishop e3 is basically
to stop bishop c5 and go for the same
plan
if possible but with and without
allowing you know move bishop c5 which
was annoying in the
previous lines so perhaps this is a
better try but still
uh knight d7 uh not h2
similar plan right but right now again
we can play move like bishop c5 for
instance
and you know this again
possibly trades the the bishops and
again k7 follows
black is pretty much very solid here i
don't think even if white is maybe
slightly better
i do not think that there is too much
reason to worry here with black
however then one very important idea
here to note
is basically the black generally should
trade those dark square bishops because
with all stars without uh sorry will
those darks were bishops
on the board uh this bishop let's say
just as we discussed in magnus versus
mvl
i would just bring this position again
um
yeah like okay a little bit later like
let's say
here so all those type of positions this
bishop all
on e7 will be always weak will always be
a sort of a problem
while if we could trade it it will
basically we are training our bad bishop
with black for a wise good bishop
therefore this should be generally
favorable to black and and you know
should give black
decent gain
and idea of you know here coming back
again to the bishop e3 move
knight d7 let's say knight h2 and bishop
c5 is exactly you know to avoid such
positions as
in mvl uh magnus mvl okay
and here again that's a knight g4 we can
play even a5
followed by king e7 at some point there
is no any issues with knight xf6
which is important uh to note because
after this this this
uh even though white has pair of bishops
uh black knight is very active this
bishop this dark square bishop
is restricted a lot it's after bishop e3
rook f8 for attacking pawn f2 that's a
king d1 and h6
this bishop is pretty much restricted
and i think black could be even better
here
because you know even it's very likely
light square bishops will be traded and
this bishop
will be still restricted
and pawns let's say pawn on h5 could
potentially be objectively attacked by
this knight on
from f6 let's say maybe in the future
so uh i think this type of position
black doesn't take any risk only black
would be better
and uh so and also knight x bishop x fc5
knight f6 also doesn't work because of
king f7 and knight d5
knight x e4 simply wins back the pawn
and again
position is pretty much around equal
so i think that this was what black
should have gone for
still white should be somewhat maybe
a tiny bit better here some moves like
maybe
i don't know bishop c4 i guess slowly
trying to do all the pieces and so on
but again move like after let's say king
e7 i don't really see any problems here
for black okay the only weakness pawn on
f6 is covered
knight is already coming to f5 because
we are still keep our bishop the bishops
are not traded so this is a very
important thing right now
uh the last dice are not traded so f5
square is not really such a big problem
and here i believe black shouldn't have
too many
problems to keep the game balanced
how of course white can try i can
definitely try
so let's move back to what happened in
the game because this is what pretty
much what i wanted to cover on
e5 which i think is the correct play
here for black
uh here in the game however uh
what happened h5 and this is uh what uh
m envio already played a few times
but he also played e5 and he played e5
recently so i'm a little bit
confused why he didn't go for e5 again
especially
that uh you know improving on the game
against magnus uh
i think it was possible uh like what we
discussed let's say after knight h2
uh bishop c5 improves basically on uh
nvidia's choice of i think knight d7
right
he played no bishop e6 he played should
be six so bishop c5 improves on bishop
e6
and it's pretty straightforward
improvement uh
so um maybe we'll see in the next games
uh however uh in this game and we chose
h5 after which he already struggled in
the past for instance there was a
game uh rapport mvl from 2015
and uh envy and maximization
struggle in this game too so let's see
what happened
right now uh black of course wants to
play right now e5
if black plays h5 and then e5 then
of course there will be even better
version of let's say regular
position after we discuss after h5 a5 h5
g5
because here at least uh black has a
control
k black and five for the control over
the light squares on a f5 g4
after let's say h4 h5 if black can get
two players
let's say after kings two e5 this would
be simply great for black
this is exactly what black hopes for uh
in this type of end game
to basically uh do not allow white to
uh you know provoke any weaknesses on
the light squares here
or the dark squares and
you know play such position and we're
just pretty equal
therefore in this position white
[Music]
temuraj above with white play move very
strong move e5 of course this is all
still theory
uh but i really really think that this
line is kind of suspicious to uh
to black and in this in the game
uh maximum version of graph had really
really big problems
uh facing this uh facing this uh line
facing this move uh knight c6 seems
logical
bishop d3 logical to attack on f7
uh and right now king of saying also
logical if bishop f5
it was possible but after let's say take
stakes rook e1
we will discuss very similar position uh
and then soon because pretty much the
same
idea and will chose against rapport so
we'll see about
we'll talk about in a second so bishop
d3 uh king f7
uh rook e1 the you know supporting pawn
on e5 makes perfect sense
and right now uh black has two
possibilities one idea is bishop
g4 one lady as bishop f5 so
which one is better bishop g4 is
more accurate because after bishop f5
this is
the game between rapper versus nvl
and here i believe y has big
advantage uh like really big advantage
because bishop f5 okay try to simplify
the position which is very
logical however after takes takes white
can play a very strong move
e6 and basically right now it's pawn on
e6
um development of bishop on fade is
is pretty much restricted it can only go
to h6 also
like a pawn black pawn structure is uh
very bad i would say uh pawn fight is a
weakness
opponent c7 could be also a weakness
um king has to go to g6
of and right but right now white has
only i think
maybe there is more moves but there is
one specifically very strong move that
white needs to play to prove the
advantage and these movies
obviously move knight to g1 a very nice
idea in this endgame
insane idea i would say even going with
the topic of this of this
lecture basically knight goes to
the initial square to
basically to find its path towards f4
and
if this knight lands on a fourth square
let's say in this way
or this way either tonight the four or
ninety three another four
this will be extremely dangerous to
to black uh you know be pretty much
it will not be playable so um
in the game from the bishop h6
uh knight e2 followed rook d8
okay king c2 logical
uh rook d6 and right now uh
rapper made a mistake richard made a
mistake uh because he played him united
f4 and after which bishop takes the f4
which should take the four even though
he seems very tempting to play like this
but suddenly you know it seems like
white is just winning because you know
rook is under attack
seven is like pinned with the rook and
the similar white simply wins the pawn
right
however after 95 positions it pretty
much simplifies very immediately to
uh equal rook endgame takes takes
rook d8 rookie 2 king f6 black simply
takes back the pawn on e6
and there are no issues whatsoever
anymore um
that's why knight f4 here would be was a
huge mistake here by uh by
richard rapport and a missed chance to
win the game
because simply bishop takes h6 followed
by
the king of h694 is totally dominating
it is simply dominating there is black's
position is
on the verge of being simply lost
strategically
pawn on e6 is well guarded upon h5 is a
weakness
not only four is extremely strong king
on h6 will be forced forever to defend
his pawn on h5
on the queen side y will just develop
you know some
second weakness create second weakness
and
and black's defense will eventually has
to pretty much collapse
so after 95 for instance rg1 you know
um even rook trade is hell
is good for for white here this push is
simply awful here
i'm uh perhaps richard rapport
didn't i'm sure he's seen this but
perhaps he thought that uh
after you know bishop f4 he just wins
the pawn or like
uh underestimated 95 or i don't know
what happened but
here basically uh there is no doubt that
white is
clearly clearly better so beat up f5
therefore his position is not the person
is not a good move
bishop therefore you play with bishop g4
try to pin
we should run away with the king king c2
and uh
right now
rda is the main move however
um okay one thing to know okay there are
two things that i wanted to know in this
position
what comes after which place is free
after bishop f3
white has to play move i think e6 in
order to
uh you know protect the pawn and
suddenly
king has nowhere ready to go because if
king goes to g7
this king will be staying in the way of
development on the
in the way of development of this fight
bishop after please say we take back
the king is disturbing the bishop to
getting to get developed quickly
and why this i think white has simply
huge advantage
and if king g8 of course is possible but
this
doesn't still resolve any problems
because put downpour manager is hanging
yes black can play move f5 but you know
this already you know creates some
weaknesses
and definitely it's let's say after f5
even i can play with bishop f4
heating with pawn on c7 at least that
there's also
a move like g1 there is uh
[Music]
yeah there's i can also begin playing on
the queen side as well
there are a bunch of possibilities uh
perhaps this was something black should
do but anyway this
position is you know pretty shaky that's
why bishop takes the three is a bad move
and however what i think is a decent
move for for
black right now is knight x e5 so uh
knight x5 seemingly you know just goes
voluntarily for a bad pawn structure if
knight takes e5
takes rook takes e5 however uh if the
closer look at this position makes
makes me think that things are far from
clear let's say if black plays e6
you know yes white has better pawn
structure
but there's only one weakness there's
only one uh
pawn only that is potentially weak
and so far well very well guarded by the
light square bishop
and the white will one sorry black would
want to play with bishop f5 trying to
trade with
the light square bishops uh for the
moves like bishop d6
rook e8 maybe somewhere maybe this rook
somewhere to d8 maybe to b8
i don't know exactly 4 by b5 so
i'm not exactly sure what plan would
white uh try to implement in this
position
in order to prove the advantage i still
think that white is slightly better than
celter you know bishop g5 bishop d6
rook e1 back bishop five again this is a
this is a good trade for
for black if this abuse plays a five
either pointer is on f5 with
is just totally quality so why should
play rook ad one
uh but here black is pretty solid i
believe just b5
i'm not sure what is what white is doing
everyone has to place
but okay king c1 just rook b8 and i am
not exactly
sure what is here white's plan um
i'm i do not see it i do not i i do not
know
uh perhaps move something like f3 g4 at
some point but this is also
a long plan because so far i would just
if this happens i will simply capture
the pawn and
that's it and yeah
like i don't know i don't i'm not
exactly sure what kind of plan
can white pursue here um
black is pretty pretty solid i would say
still white can definitely try move like
you know maybe bishop e4
followed by f3 uh double the rooks on
the e file
um all of this could be tried but
with correct play i feel like black
should have enough resources to
you know maintain you know the balance
uh but i believe this is something what
black should have gone for
here uh even though uh this
uh move you know is has never been
played only in this position of the
kings 2
95 knife was never played but only move
that had been played was rook d8
and this is what mvl went for but here
in this position
uh i think that um temura java made a
mistake
uh because in this position bishop f4 uh
was uh demus temu's choice
and this move i think suppose
if not entire advantage and at least big
part of the advantage
and the point is right after bishop f4
bishop h6
i would i was i'll come back into this
position after before bishop before in a
moment
but let's see and let's understand first
why bishop f4 is a mistake
in my opinion because right now after
bishop h6 i
um i think that black is in time to you
know
solve all the opening problems uh due to
tactical uh
let's say reasons the thing is it's very
similar
uh to after let's say bishop sorry
bishop g3 after bishop
h6 sorry we lost the tempo right because
uh
h6 could have been let's say if here
black plays bishop h6
uh okay at least there is no rook on the
eight
so uh this kind of like is not uh
something that black would normally
wants to do while it wants to black
wants to wait for bishop before we play
bishop h6 that's why okay the
a bishop before bishop h6 has been
played
so here if bishop takes h6 rook plays h6
um pawn only five is sort of object of
the attack right now
so make sense we need to play bishop e4
try to eliminate knight from c6
but uh you know and also you know if
bishop takes a free then uh y will be
slightly better after bishop plays the
three
for instance also e6 could be you know
very testing as well
uh but after even bishop takes the three
could be you know some edge but e6 i
think is pretty
even more testing than than other moves
and
after this let's say this this this
position should be better for white
because
bishop is better than the knight and the
pawn e6
is uh in this position by bishop is
better than knight because we're gonna
put this pressure here into this
diagonal
and paul e6 is rather stronger than a
weak because
maybe we can play d1 with d7 sometimes
uh
so it is i think white is better here
so um and of course another thing white
black sorry black cannot tape because
bishop takes c6 and we take
the check discovery check and then we
take back the bishop and we
retain extra piece so um
here black should play after bishop e4
bishop f5
so seemingly this uh resembles what
happened in the game
uh mvl sorry rapport mvl right
however there's a huge huge difference
after bishop takes f5 gtx 5
e6 king g6 you know normally we would
like already to have our knight
let's say on e2 uh to or let's say on g1
to play knight on e2 and then knight f4
basically uh
to to make you know to bring this knight
to f4
because if we do not bring the design to
f4 i do not think the black white has
simply anything here
uh because uh after knight g1 black can
play move f4
very strong move and silently king comes
to f5 a signal h3 king f5
pawn on e6 is a weakness right now
because we can play 95 and surround the
spawn only six
also logistics logistics could be played
king nfl is very active
i think black can simply if nobody is if
not better already black can quickly
at least has chance to simply take over
pretty soon
so um that's why black
white is simply not in time to install
design on f4 because of f4 move
um
[Music]
yeah that's the that's that that's the
main difference here and
even if bishop g3 this is what the
teamwork above play
right now uh black has actually two
paths to
to equality uh but both of them start
with bishoprics f3 now king g7 was uh
king g7 was a very mysterious move
by mvl which i do not understand
um instead simple bishop takes a free
lease to immediately quality
in a very very simple way because after
gtx 3
black can play knight either knight x e5
and just you know trade everything here
of course black
black has no any issues let's say on
group d6 for instance sakura securing
on the pawn on g6 maybe rook f6 idea
maybe bishop f4 e5
no issues here whatsoever um
and also a possibility to play with f5
uh which is less a little bit more
ambitious i guess
because uh right now white should be
playing f4
in order not to you know black black
threatens f4 sort of
you know to kind of like uh trap the
bishop on this
uh more like more i close this bishop or
i lock this b on h2
so i should play with f4 and then the
right signal right now simply e6
and here you know also i do not see any
problems here for black i think
maybe even the long-term perspective uh
the knight
because of the close character of the
position could be better than the pair
of bishops
and more like nine bishop could be
better than the pair of bishops because
of the close nature of the push
of this position that's why i think that
you know bishop takes a free uh gtx 3
doesn't give anything
and e6 seems like tempting move but
anywhere after king g7
takes and f5 also black does not have
any any problems and uh
to be honest uh i tried to analyze a
little bit
further and uh okay everywhere
black is pretty much doing well and
white doesn't have any advantage
a and however the most notably uh
white cannot capture on c7 there are
many reasons why this this is this does
this fails
but one of the nicest ways to exploit us
please please be very strong move
rook d5 followed by rook c8 and
this bishop has to go from somewhere has
to go from 7 to somewhere
and then before ideas are you know
unavoidable they say rook cl would
follow
then maybe bishop if i would still sort
of hold it together
because it comes with the check and the
you know
uh 95 rupee 5 is around equal
however rook d5 is a nice prophylaxis
preparing rook c8 and black simply
wins so this is a nice idea here for for
black for instance uh
i know f4 i try to try to make if i work
again bishop if i work anyway but rook
c8
there rpg5 and right now very nice idea
group takes e5
and four by nine before and the game is
just pretty much over
because uh takes knight knight before
king d2 which plays f4
rookie free who simply tried everything
and king of six let's say and police is
lost
black wins upon and has totally winning
organ game
uh so this is the
the the point so bishop
that's why i think the idea of bishop f4
and bishop g3 is
uh you know not a good idea
but instead in this position let's come
back let's go back here here white could
have played uh
tables could have played one move that i
think that
grants a huge advantage for dwight which
is bishop e4
and the idea of bishop e4 is
basically improving on what bishop f4
has in mind so
sort of and the the interesting far part
of this
is that bishop e4 has been played
already there was game i think in 2012
um i think 2012 has versus kurnosov
and robert hess with white uh
had very very nice position and he was
close to winning but eventually came in
with a draw however he played bishop
before and got
immediately big advantage of the opening
and
yeah bishop b4 is by far i think the the
best move here
and after bishop e4 bishop h6
takes takes bishop takes bishop takes c6
and beat after b take c6 sim well right
now uh you know okay
bishop h6 makes sense right uh actually
playing
h6 which basically makes sense we need
to somehow develop the bishop from f8
so it makes us to play this rook bishop
h6 move but we can already see comparing
to the position with bishop f4
i'll show it again after bishop before
bishop h6 bishop h6
uh rook h6 you know uh sorry rook h6
uh essentially we are down the tempo in
this position that's why bishop 4 is i
think inaccurate
bishop e4 on the other hand is very
strong because in the same position
we have bishop on e4 and right now we
can basically capture on c6
the string black spawn structure and
right now
i think the best move for white is to
play move simply rook
e3 and idea of rook e3 is again just
double on the e file and basically maybe
threaten it takes f6
and at some point knight d4 would
definitely
become handy and the the thing is that
bishop f5 is never really a concern
because i can just play kim b3 and this
group b is just one check i can go k3
there is no follow-up here whatsoever
uh rook ae1 comes in knight d4 comes in
position is very bad for uh for black
and and if black tries to simplify the
position of bishop takes a free
then route is a three rook d5 simply
rookie one
and you know a [ __ ] probably sooner or
later has to be played because otherwise
black white will take on ef6 and try to
invade over a file
uh but right now after f5 the white you
can invade through the fourth rank
and the rook a4 c4 ideas are pretty much
uh unstoppable and white should should
win this end game
so i think bishop e4 okay one more thing
before is knight takes e5 in this
position uh
you know we can simply take take b7 and
this end game even though
uh it may seem to be similar uh
you know the previous one uh like
let me just show it quickly uh
to this position right because also
knives are traded
here in this position the one that we
had just now on the board
uh the the level is quite substantial
because we got to
take a b7 pawn and those e pawns are
doubled
so black sponsors totally destroyed and
we can simply locate
on e4 and we have three verses on the
queen side and you can easily push
them forward or even maybe win somehow
a7 if we can
white should be uh why should we win
this
or at least the white has you know big
advantage that i can so that i can tell
for sure
i can say for sure so uh that that being
said
i think bishop e4 uh generally gives
black uh
really really big problems to solve and
to be honest i am not sure what envel
has planned here
um but uh
i don't know maybe the maybe in the next
games nvl will show
uh what he had in mind here however uh
you know
i think that white is simply much better
after movie show before and uh
i do not see i i could i did from what i
analyzed i couldn't find here equality
uh so yeah
and but in the game follow bishop f4
let's see what happened in the game
bishop h6 bishop g3 and right now uh
nvl played king g7 which is a little bit
mysterious
move he should have played you know uh
as i said bishop takes the three and
just simplifying the position
of equality after king g7 right now
[Music]
um
e4 which is a definitely a good move
however
after knight a5 i do not see anything
better than just repetition of bishop d3
knight c6 for both sides
and perhaps here white uh okay timer
could have played with b4 or something
like this the same position so i could
move back here
uh after kingston immediately before
also was possible
is just the same thing and i think in
this position white should somehow
uh be better of idea is basically
to play bishop e4 and um
i think that yeah uh that this position
should be player for white the point is
that right now
it's not so great to you know all those
lines with taking on
e5 are not great because king isn't just
running into some checks
um
yeah k17 doesn't pretty much it's not
useful at all
and only helps white in this in this
instance
so a weird decision by mvl but okay it
was rapid chess maybe he forgot his
preparation or something
um i i don't know but okay
in the game for bishop e4
f5 and yeah the f5 this was basically
a final mistake here by mvl to be honest
because after f5 this end game
suddenly is totally horrible totally
horrible for mvl
uh uh again the only move was knight a5
to you know just to try to hang on there
and not to
allow destroy the pawn structure and say
after uh
before look for contrary with knight c4
or something like that
just look for active counterplay
and
f5 on the other hand is simply a big
strategic mistake
after bishop take c6 beat x6 knight g5
okay i understand that angel has planned
you know f4 here but
i can be easily buried by a knight g5
fretting 96 so that probably
will buy black should take when pawn
takes and this end game
is suddenly nearly
nearly lost it's if not lost
if not just lost so uh i i simply think
that
this was a huge here uh mistake by
um you know mvl and that took that he
allowed to
uh to go for such end game and um
allowed white to go for an entertainment
end game because right now this bishop
on g4 is a big problem it cannot
quickly join the game uh you know it's
sort of trapped there right so the only
way to bring it to the game
like okay the best the most logical
let's say path
humans play f4 uh there was also h4 but
you know f4 is let's say you know making
room for this bishop on f5 which is will
say very
human but it gives a pawn on the other
hand so we should take the f4
rook f8 just bishop e3 and there is no
need to play g3 because it basically
creates something of maybe of h4 there
is no need to allow this
right now um uh tamora rojo presents a
very nice technique
and you know he was winning for the
majority of the game
in the end there was only one moment
where uh
like mvr could have basically put more
resistance
uh but you know he
kind of collapsed but okay let's see
what kind of strategy
uh tamir above shot in this particular
position
bishop e3 bishop f5 king b3
rook d5 and simply
c4 basically white is winning here
because
uh no even despite the fact that you
know there are the opposite political
bishops
which sometimes okay or more like is
often
thought that they are uh giving uh or
like you know
they should give some drawing drawing
chances
in reality uh
it is not so not so obvious especially
when there are rooks on the board
uh with focus on the board there are
huge chances you know of
something sacrificing the exchange and
transferring to the end game
with bishop versus rook whether wherever
uh
bishop supports past pawns and the rook
cannot do absolutely anything
there are in some such instances and
here also
we have to see that black pawns here
are all weak they're all very weak
and they are just gonna be falling uh
soon or soonish so in the game for rook
d3 and right now king a4
the king feels extremely comfortable
here on the side of the board because of
this bath bomb structure
the king comes to a5 on the dark square
we play b3
maybe we can play bishop c5 the king
doesn't run into any single check
can even threaten after his rooks are
traded to basically just
start collecting all the black pawns
here on the queen side and the game here
is pretty much over
uh the of course both players fall
really hard
uh b3 rook d8 king a5 as i said king
goes to a5
a6 bishop c5 uh king e6 uh okay uh
repeating moves or like maybe he was
maybe was time trouble or something he
was rapid
rapid game it doesn't really matter uh
strategically white is still completely
winning
there's absolutely nothing that black
can do
gradually improving the position it
comes maybe to h4
uh which are back to c5 exactly rook to
each other as i said
uh and g4 is possible i'm not sure if
this was the best
play the best play here uh i'll consider
also a movie like group d4 trying to
trade pair of rogues
maybe try another pair of roofs just
collecting all the pawns and
making sure you know that uh you know
the black has no counterplay
g4 also is possible uh you know for
battle gage too
but this maybe creates some chances here
to for black to save this game
anyway this we are already acting less
interested in
because uh the you know here already
wife
was weighing pretty much almost almost
everywhere
uh in the end i wouldn't just want to
quickly show one position
uh around here whenever um
yeah basically here uh wherever mvl
blundered
because he played with this move king d7
which is
really really unfortunate uh because
uh you know of course his question is
not like
not to be not too envy that i'm not
really you know
uh jealous of black's position right now
but it's definitely could have been
fall a little bit longer if he played
something
uh or if he didn't blunder simply root
seven which immediately loses so for
right now
basically the only uh maybe not only but
the best let's say defense was to play
move
ruger free and uh of course the game
went out of control for routine rajabov
but
you know out of the opening of basically
this
opening end game he got very big
advantage
and that's the let's say the most
important part that i wanted to focus on
in this
lecture so in the game here in
black would have still fall for a draw
of rook f3 and let's say threatening
ruger free mate
well what should have played move a4 in
this case
and perhaps move like king
sorry not king but rook f7 just stopping
you know just protecting here attacking
here
in this pawn uh this would have given a
better chances to to make a draw here uh
still of course white will be trying to
win this
there are certain certain chances taking
on a6 the key on e7
but it is i i do not think this is
a easy twin anymore here uh with
with black and sorry with white uh
definitely
temura summer on the way miss his chance
and
but the most important thing that you
need to get such position like
the following one out of the opening is
having a great
great great achievement uh the first
strategy i would focus and i will repeat
it again
let's say i'm not sure exactly sure
about movies move g4 without considering
here is basically trade uh basically one
pair of rogues at least
uh because the rook on d4 rugby on d1 is
very very annoying
after training one pair of ropes this
will be delegated solely defending pawn
on a6
then we can slowly you know uh activate
our own rook maybe
riemann regroup king and bishop let's
say
change with the squares and say after
just some random analysis let's say it
is this
maybe we can bring our king to c5 attack
spawn on c6 bring our bishop to a5
uh so let's say i don't know move like
our same please just show uh
idea here and maybe bishop comes back
here
and let's say bishop is okay this is
already
this already loses because rook d2 comes
into play also
so uh black cannot just stay in place
black can simply stay in place
the game should be won by wide
this was i think a little bit better
strategy my teammates have played g4
which i think
created some check under chances for mvl
and
but eventually i think that uh you know
after having such an advantage uh he
should have won somehow either way
eventually
but okay so this was this game
i wanted to quickly just really quickly
show uh what happened in the second game
between those two great players
uh which was it with the same opening
which possibly uh
will be you know under
uh you know so we we had enough time to
discuss this game
uh because the previous one was so
interesting in my opinion at least
uh in this end game but here 97
basically is the second game that uh
mahama shallagraph played and here the
idea is basically to
play without move e5 it will basically
try to play more dynamic chess
this other strategy here by by
a black which is you know possible
bishop f4 knight c5 you see knight right
now a knight
comes quickly to c5 attacking pawn on e4
so white doesn't have time to play the
capture pawn on c7
why should play knight d2 and simply
bishop d7
and white goes sorry black goes simply
for compensation here
and
[Music]
this is you know another possible
strategy
here by uh by black
it is good to uh i i mean i think that
um this could be you know
maybe you know ever since this game this
could be
main choice by uh mvl in his future
uh you know games and so on uh
especially that right now white cannot
okay white can't sort of
capture opponent c7 black but black will
have very strong compensation after move
uh bishop h6 and basically brings bishop
to this diagonal
uh threatening maybe she takes it to at
some point uh
you know going for compensation and
without kind of like having to you know
fighting defensively
uh for uh for a draw uh with uh
moves like f6 e5 and so on and playing
fair after position with bohr's pawn
structure
here is more dynamic way of approaching
this opening uh
and if but okay while of course will not
be capturing this pawn and the instead
of happened f3
in the game which g7 king c2 b5
and basically i want to show you
the game up to a point where basically i
think
mvl had good game and had good position
but he made one mistake and ever since
they
basically the entire game went downhill
uh went south
and so after bishop b3 knight a4 knight
b3
a6 bishop e2 is logical i'm not sure if
this was the best move to be honest but
okay knight c5 takes takes
bishop e5 very nice move by mvl
basically brings bishop to d6
again we do not play e5 we don't really
need this move e5
instead bishop comes to e5 and we use
this e5 square to
bring this bishop to the queen side so
bishop e5 bishop d6
so in this position uh team retro play
move
after bishop a5 a4 so
uh in i believe
that in this position uh even though
white has some chances what is maybe
slightly slightly better uh i think that
black should sort of be able to
hold it if only black captures
b takes a4 of course white is still
better
somewhat but b takes a4 is sort of a
must
you cannot just not take it on a4 in
this position because
if you don't take on a4 you will
basically suffer until uh the end of the
game just like
the uh jose and will suffer in this game
against temura jabot
and it's kind of like playing on two
results pretty much either white
manages to convert or or doesn't and
you know in the end tamerajob managed to
win this
but here in this position b takes a4 has
to be played and the explanation of b64
is simple
uh you cannot allow black to white to
open the a file if white opens the a
file
the game will be you know
you know play basically on two two
results therefore uh b takes a4 has to
be played even though
it messes up the pawn structure but
right now bishop takes a6 let's say rule
b8
uh rook b8 and
yeah i'm not okay perhaps
black can play move like h4 or some sort
or h4 maybe bishop c4 at first
bring you know somehow the pieces
together maybe surround the spawn lay
for somehow
but still move like uh at some point
bishop d6
i'm sorry um so uh in
in here pawnee four is still well
guarded by this bishop on d7
and it's not clear how white can you
know convert
this kind of like quickly or like get
some clear edge
quickly uh so this is what basically had
to be played
instead uh uh mvl played i think pretty
quickly bishop d6 maybe it was too
hasty's decision
after bishop takes takes attacks b5 it
takes b5
rook a7 white fully has full control
over the a file
who comes under comes to a1 and even
though black is still kind of solid
uh it is definitely at the very
difficult position for black to play
and eventually uh taymur oh job of
winning winning this game
and overall he he won the
the match for the third place in opera
uh
rapid tour so um
yeah that's pretty much all i have for
to for today i think
all those end games are interesting i
played them
myself mostly with black i don't think i
played them too often with white
mostly i think some blitz games but with
black i played them
quite i played a few times because i
played grundfault mostly a few years ago
quite exclusively recently a little bit
less but still
and here and i i think that both end
games are very interesting
and they lead to a bad really
interesting
fight and usually white is considered to
be slightly better but
black but
okay usually uh in this type of let's
say end game just
bring it against the initial position if
king takes d1 in this point
is again i think also thinking that uh
black easily equalizes but the as the
theory suggests uh
other new games such as new research new
analysis and so on
so just things may be not entirely easy
especially that
uh such expert like maxima shiloh graph
has been switching between lines f6
one game 97 another game so he and he
loves him both
so it means that something's out here
something maybe
there could be some problems that uh you
know at least maybe not
even if like real problems agree some
practical problems who still could be
uh problematic over in over the board
so yeah i think
the that's all from me for today uh i
hope the game
i hope you guys enjoyed it and i will
see you
next time thanks